hey this is presh talwalkar
team a has four girls and seven boys
team a takes five days to paint four
rooms
team b has seven girls and ten boys
team b takes four days to paint five
rooms
team c has eight girls and five boys
how long will it take team c to paint
six rooms
assume every girl works at a constant
rate every boy works at a constant rate
and every room is identical
this problem was posted to quora and
suggested to me by ole dele from nigeria
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so let's set up some variables
let lowercase g be the percentage of a
room a girl paints daily
let capital g be the number of girls
working on a team
then capital g times lowercase g will be
the number of rooms that capital g girls
paint daily
we can set up similar variables for boys
let lowercase b equal the percentage of
a room a boy paints daily
let capital b equal the number of boys
working on a team then capital b times
lowercase b equals the number of rooms
capital b boys paint daily
now if we multiply
each of these by t days
we get the number of rooms that either g
girls or b boys paint in t days
now team a has four girls and seven boys
and it takes five days to paint four
rooms
so we add up the work that the girls do
and the work that the boys do to get a
total of four rooms
so this translates into the following
equation we have five times the quantity
four g plus five times the quantity
seven b is equal to 4.
5 times the quantity 4g is the amount of
work that the girls are doing and 5
times the quantity 7b is the amount of
work that the boys are doing to get a
total of 4 rooms
now for team b we can set up a similar
equation
we have four times the quantity seven g
plus four times the quantity ten b
equals five
now for team c
we know the number of girls and the
number of boys and we know that there
are six rooms and we want to solve for
the variable t
so we have t times the quantity 8g plus
5b equals 6.
so how can we solve for t
well let's take a look at the first two
equations we set up
we can rewrite the first equation as 20g
plus 35b equals four
the second equation becomes 28g plus 40b
is equal to 5.
now if we subtract the first equation
from the second we get eight g plus five
b is equal to one
and that exactly matches what we want to
find in team c
so just algebraically if we multiply
both sides by 6 we can see that t has to
be equal to 6.
we can also interpret the answer
if 8g plus 5b is equal to 1 that means 8
girls and 5 boys can paint one room in
one day
therefore it will take six days for team
c to paint six rooms
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math you can catch me on my blog mind
your decisions if you like this video
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon if you have a
math topic you can email me presh
mindyourdecisions.com and you can catch
me on social media either at mind your
decisions or at presh tallwalker